في كتب اعتقلت الشرطه احد عناصرها لاشتباك
باطلاقه النار خارج ساعات خدمته على شبين
من الاقليه الصربيه واصابتهما قرب بلده
شريس مسا وادانا رئيس وزراء كوسوفو البين
كورتي الهجوم على الشابين معربا عن قلقه
البالغ على حالتهما في سياق متصل زادت
الشرطه دوريتها عقب الحادثه كما قالت قوه
حفظ السلام التي يقودها النيته في فوطه
انها اعززت اجراءتها ودوريتها وانها لا
تنوي زياده عدد جنودها ولم تتلقى اي طلب
رسميا بذلك من حكومه بريشتينا ياتي هذا
التطور بعد ايام قليله من ازاله حواجز
نصبها شمالي البلاد لاسابيع احتجاجا على
قرارات لحكومه كتفه في الاجتماع
هذا وقد ادانا الاتحاد الاوروبي بشده
اطلاق النار على طفل وشاب من الاقليه
الصربيه عشيه اعياد الميلاد وقال المتحدث
باسمي مفوض العلاقات الخارجيه الاوروبيه
ان من المهم ان تحقق السلطات بشكل كامل في
هذه الجريمه التي وصفها بالنكره وتحقيق
العداله
الاكاديمي والخبير في العلاقات
كيف تصفون وضع
اثر هذا الحادث في ظلي تعقيدات الوضع
الحالي هل هو مرشح للاحتواء ام رشا
التصعيد
هذه الحوادث
النساء
من قبل كانت مستندات اثباتهاويه
ولو حتى تعريف السياره الان اطلق نار على
شخصين واصيب
كل من هذه الحوادث يؤدي الى وضع الحواجز
ولكن ايضا
اوف ديوتي
تابعه لصربيا وقوات امن كوسوفو هذه هي
المشكله الرئيسيه هذا قد يؤدي الى خطر
كبير اولا الاطراف الضالعه مباشره ولكن
ايضا بالنسبه الى المنطقه بيرومتها وانا
ادرك تماما لان قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه
اوك
بسكوبي باصات
شمال الاطلسي يحاولنا ان يضبطوا الوضع من
خلال عدد القوات الموجود حاليا اذا شهد
الوضع تسعيدا حين ذلك فان قوات انيته في
الاحتياطي في تلك المنطقه
بالمنطقه فقط ولكن ايضا هناك عوامل
ومؤشرات خارجيه هي التي تؤثر على الوضع
بما فيه تصرف
النظام الروسي
يا اه اه اه طبعا حتى
قبل هذه المستجدات التي شهدتها كوسوفورا
اين تاثيرا كبيرا وتدخلا كبيرا لروسيا في
صربيا والبوسنه والهرسك والموتو في كوسوفو
تحاولوا روسيا ان تتسبب بازمه اخرى
بي بما يؤدي
الى تفاعل اكبر من قبل قوات النيته هذا
يعني ان هذه الازمه في كوسوفو يا لمصلحه
روسيا وروسيا
وجدت وكالات لاسيه ما بين السياسيين الصرب
من اجل ان يخدموا مصالحها احد هذه
التحركات من قبل السياسيين المحليين هو
ابتعال هذه الحوادث والنشر هذه الازمه في
المنطقه
شكرا لك من سراييفو اليا كوزلاكال
كاكاديمي والخبير في العلاقات الدوليه